by the way new york governor andrew
cuomo remember that guy just wrote a
book about how well he handled cover 19
remember that
he wrote a whole book about american
crisis or he had a ghostwriter do it for
him and then he
ran around on tv traipsing around on tv
talking about what a wonderful job he
did
handling covet even though his covet
curve looked exactly like the bad curve
in the bad versus good curve and this is
the who was appearing with his
brother on national tv every night to do
a comedy bit where his brother
showed up with a giant q-tip to talk
about the size of his nose
this guy was hero of the republic andrew
cuomo while tens of thousands of people
died in his state
as he was shipping the olds back into
the nursing homes with kovid
okay so here is andrew cuomo having have
after having
precipitously and preemptively written a
book about how wonderfully he did with
covid announcing astronomical increases
happening in new york state
western new york worst situation
in the state of new york in western new
york
these are the highest rates
9.7 9.4 7.5 7.3 6.8
dramatically higher than anywhere else
it's those areas which are
astronomical compared to
the rest of the state okay you know
which part is not astronomical the
schools the schools are not astronomical
he's talking about rates of seven
eight nine percent in these particular
areas again new york city public schools
0.23 positivity rate again they're
shutting down the schools
also just worthy of note andrew cuomo
has blamed every single thing in the
universe except for himself for his bad
handling of covet
all the things right he's blamed he's
blamed president trump he has blamed god
he has blamed republicans he has blamed
the press he's blamed everybody well all
this came to a head yesterday
when a wall street journal reporter
asked him about the school closures
and cuomo was not up on the news right
so cuomo immediately started firing back
by suggesting the schools were not
closed and he didn't know what he was
talking about and the wall street
journal reporter was like well i feel
like parents are kind of confused
because you're saying one thing and de
blasio's saying another
here is andrew cuomo engaged in a
vicious attack on the press
if trump had done this this would have
been the story for the next 48 hours
minimum
andrew cuomo abuses a member of the
press by suggesting that uh that member
of the press is confused and terrible
for asking a very straightforward
question
the answer is this state is run like
crap okay it is wrong
andrew cuomo is a bad governor he's a
bad governor and bill de blasio is a bad
mayor and everybody knows it
here is andrew cuomo going nuts on a
member of the press
what are you talking about you're now
going to override
we did it already that's the law an
orange zone in a red zone
follow the facts still confused well
then you're confused
i'm confused parents are still confused
as well
they're school they're not confused
you're confused no i think parents are
confused as well read the law and you
won't be confused
okay but we're confused because what the
law says is that if you get above a
certain positivity rate the schools can
be shut down but new york city
and new york state were reporting
different rates of positivity for new
york city
andrew cuomo is confused because he has
been in this running gun battle with
bill de blasio the two hate each other
it's been this ridiculous mutton jeff
routine
for a while here it's it's absurd it's
absurd but don't worry these are the
people who are following the signs
they know what to do ron desantis and
greg abbott they're the bad ones
but andrew cuomo hero of the republic
bill de blasio handling this thing like
a champ
while he's out there rallying for joe
biden and having people paint murals
on fifth avenue in the middle of a
pandemic slow clap for the science right
there
a lot a lot of science following i am
seeing i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the ben shapiro show if you did go ahead
and hit the subscribe button so you stay
up to date on all of our future content